Yes ! Super !
Il y a de la neige partout
et en plus il fait pas très chaud,
des conditions idéales
pour se faire une petite fondue
au fromage, bien sûr.
Chauffe Marcel !
J’adore tremper un morceau
de pain dans la fondue.
J’ai l’impression d’être à la montagne.
Le caquelon vous savez c’est cette casserole
en terre cuite ou en fonte,
pourvue d’un manche et dans laquelle
on prépare et puis on sert la fondue.
Ce nom arrive tout droit de la partie
francophone de la Suisse,
ce qu’on appelle la Suisse romande.
Le mot  Kakel, qui signifie
«casserole en terre cuite»
est devenu caquelon en traversant
la frontière franco-suisse.
Et maintenant que je vous ai
mis l’eau à la bouche avec ma fondue,
plongeons dans les secrets de sa recette
qui mérite bien que l’on en fasse
tout un fromage.
Attends-moi, hein.
L’origine de la fondue,
n’en déplaise aux savoyards,
est officiellement suisse.
Et oui ! C’est chez les helvètes
que l’on trouve
la première recette écrite de fondue,
dans un manuscrit datant de 1699.
Intitulée
« Pour cuire le fromage avec du vin ».
Elle correspond à peu près
à la recette actuelle.
Ce qui ne signifie pas pour autant
qu’elle ait été inventée à ce moment-là.
Les gardiens de troupeaux
des Alpes et des pré-Alpes
s’en nourrissaient depuis bien longtemps.
Avant le XVIIIème siècle, le fromage était
pour les citadins un produit de luxe.
Mais dans les montagnes, les bergers
ou les garçons vachers, eux,
en consommaient plus régulièrement.
Et on peut imaginer que des morceaux
de pain trempés
dans des restes de fromages fondus
aient pu donner, ici et là,
les premières fondues au fromage.
Le fromage est ensuite
descendu des montagnes,
sa consommation s’est généralisée
et avec elle, celle de la fondue.
Depuis 1950, celle-ci est un plat
emblématique de la Suisse.
Et aussi, de l’autre côté de la frontière,
en Savoie et en Haute-Savoie.
Même si il n’est pas interdit
d’en manger ailleurs, même ici chez moi.
Alors quelle différence entre
les fondues suisses et les fondues savoyarde?
Le fromage bien sûr.
Chaque pays, et au sein de ceux-ci
chaque région, a sa recette,
à base de fromages plus ou moins locaux.
Dans le canton suisse de Fribourg par exemple,
la fondue est dite « moitié-moitié »
Moitié-moitié ?
Moitié pour toi, moitié pour moi ?
Mais non, pas moitié pour toi,
moitié pour moi.
Moitié vacherin fribourgeois,
moitié gruyère!
Dans le canton du Valais,
situé au Sud de la Suisse,
on ajoute au «moitié-moitié»
du raclette,
un fromage à base de lait cru de vache,
une spécialité de la région qui
s’utilise aussi pour la raclette.
En Savoie, c’est différent:
ce sont principalement l’emmental de Savoie,
le comté ou le beaufort qui font
la spécificité de la recette.
Personnellement et sûrement
parce que je suis très gourmand
j’ajoute de l’appenzell et de l’abondance
pour réaliser ma fondue aux 5 fromages.
D’autres ajoutent plutôt du reblochon. Et vous ?
Toutes les idées sont les bienvenues
N’hésitez pas à nous les partager.
Ce qui compte avec ces fromages,
c’est bien sûr qu’ils fondent bien,
Démonstration, le fromage,
c’est, en simplifiant beaucoup,
du lait dont les protéines
se sont liées les unes aux autres,
en formant des sortes de pelotes
un peu comme des pelotes de laine.
Si lorsque ces pelotes se forment,
elles emprisonnent peu d’eau et de gras,
ou si le fromage est trop vieux
ou s’il est trop acide,
eh bien ces pelotes ne se déferont
pas comme il faut sous l’action de la chaleur.
Le fromage pourra ramollir ou fondre
mais il ne sera pas élastique.
Le choix des fromages pour
une bonne fondue est donc tout un art.
Il faut qu’ils soient assez gras,
assez riches en eau,
assez jeunes, mais pas trop acides
et avec du goût quand même.
Ce n’est qu’avec de telles qualités
que les pelotes de protéines se dérouleront
et se ré-agenceront sous l’effet de la chaleur,
glisseront les unes par rapport aux autres
et formeront enfin ces longs fils, si amusants
à dérouler le plus loin possible
avant de les engloutir.
Tiens, essayez donc avec
de la feta ou du parmesan,
ça marche pas !
Ah ! C’est de la feta.
L’autre ingrédient-clé de la fondue,
c’est le vin blanc, avec modération bien sûr.
Et il n’est pas là que pour le goût.
Il joue aussi son petit rôle dans la chimie de la fondue,
l’acide tartrique qu’il contient fragilise
les liaisons entre les pelotes de protéines
du fromage et contribue à mieux
faire fondre ce dernier.
Pour équilibrer un peu, la fondue
peut être accompagnée d’une salade verte.
Un conseil qui vaut aussi pour un autre
plat à base de fromage :
la raclette, dont les Français sont
aussi complètement fondus
Ce plat, également d’origine suisse,
a conquis le pays,
au total, chaque foyer consomme entre 800 grammes
et 1 kilo de fromage à raclette par an.
Il faut dire qu’il y en a pour tous les goûts.
Nature, à l’ail des ours,
aux herbes, au poivre, fumé, etc.
Bref, 71% des Français préfèreraient
d’ailleurs la raclette à la fondue.
Et vous ?
Lequel de ces deux plats préférez-vous ?
Dites-le moi en commentaire
pendant que je déguste ma fondue et ma raclette.
Allez on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau “Sur la planche”,
Chers Épicurieuse, chers Épicurieux à très vite !